trente ans jour pour jour l'acteur et
chanteur yves montand nous quittait il
vous l'entente est décédé cet après midi
d'un infarctus à l'âge de 70 ans le
biographe emmanuel bonini soit un livre
consacré à l'artiste où il retrace sa
vie avec ses succès sa carrière
mouvementée mais aussi ses secrets dans
ce livre de 600 pages l'auteur rend un
bel hommage à yves montand il nous fait
aussi des révélations surprenantes sur
sa face cachée
expliquer sa relation avec les femmes
dont marilyn monroe et simone signoret
des soupçons sur sa fille cachée ou
encore ses affaires d'héritage tout est
passé au peigne fin alors trente ans
après sa mort êtes vous choqué par les
révélations sur yves montand le grand
père de benjamin castaldi alors merci
emmanuel bonini d'être avec nous le
véritable montant aux éditions pygmalion
et on apprend énormément de choses yves
montand c'est vrai que le hasard fait
que c'est le grand papa de mariama
castaldi alors il ya on apprend plein de
choses déjà merci d'être là dans le
niveau vêtements sur l'histoire de
l'actrice française dernier a aidé son
fils vincent 54 elle serait tombée
enceinte d'yves montand et simone
signoret et d'aurélie dié alors de se
démerder et qu'elle ne voulait pas
entendre parler de cet enfant ou oui
tout à fait c'est une histoire qui est
très connu dans la profession
française vermillard était une star du
doublage d'accord tout le monde connaît
cette histoire ils ont essayé de madame
français de vernis à a essayé de faire
reconnaître mon le petit ça n'a pas
marché via un intermédiaire voilà
d'accord et et vous connais tu
recommandes cette histoire non pas du
tout donc vous ne saviez pas ça non
d'accord vous avez lu le livre
d'emmanuel j'ai parcouru parcouru c'est
à dire vous avez jugé non j'ai parcouru
j'ai commencé mais on s'est eu au
téléphone je vous dit tout le bien que
je pensais de lui au téléphone n'a pas
voulu dire et on s'attend que voilà donc
sur ces métiers papou n'étiez pas pour
moi j'ai pas être pour ou contre chacun
écrit ce qu'il veut et on est ici long
pour en parler on donne la parole à tout
le monde mais je ne vois pas je vois pas
l'intérêt de ce livre
des histoires qui seront racontées
d'aider les enfants par les plus
regardées thereon repas par exemple qui
est que la famille était tout à fait au
camp des enfants cachés d'yves montand
qu'est ce que c'est que ces histoires
des enfants cachés bah c'est pas de
l'enfant caché ses enfants naturels la
dernière conversation j'ai eu avec pas
jamais on s'est vus plusieurs fois il
était très sympa ah oui on a parlé la
dernière fois je l'appelais je lui dit
gg maintenant je sais qu'il est mon
temps parce qu'il m'avait dit je
prendrai deux heures pour t'expliquer
équipements mon grand-père sympa et
après j'ai rappelé parce que parce que
parce que j'avais découvert tous âges
avaient travaillé pendant trois ans
c'est ça et voilà est a lyon je lui
parle et j'ai dit que j'avais découvert
un enfant et il m'a dit mais il y en a
plusieurs et la famille reconnaît
benjamin d'accord benjamin castaldi
j'enregistre tous sains
et suite à ça quand j'ai dit que
j'allais parler de la sphère de retard
benjamin qu'on recharge est rien du tout
la perdre sa l'ordre ça au pardon aux
ordres ça va faire trop tard ce benjamin
s'est mis à hurler au téléphone si tu
pars de ça tu voir toute la famille
dessus et moi je dis mais aussi s'il ya
des choses à attaquer vous attaquerez
alors il me dit non ça va pas se passer
comme ça chaque fois que tu fais une
émission de télévision je viendrai
derrière je connais tout le monde à la
télévision
j'en ai parlé d'un truc est alors moi
j'ai pris ça comme des menaces et j'ai
envoyé ça à un
avocat qui s'appelle olivier morice qui
a pris acte de sa voix lasse et le fret
ainsi que parce que je trouve que c'est
nul quoi gier surtout que moi avec ce
qu'a écrit benjamin castaldi sur son
grand père je veux dire en disant que
c'était un obsédé sexuel dans le déni
quand il s'est fait j'ai déçu les cartes
dans quoi je l'écris c'est pareil dans
quoi tu auras skelling dans le ligue
américaine kelly nké page quelle phrase
quelle page web c'était un obsédé sexuel
ce type était un véritable scénario j'ai
déjà avoir fait moi le truc il faudra
c'est à dire bien sûr mais mais bien sûr
c'était clan perché jolie fille à ça il
ya plein d'autres choses aussi
et qu'est ce que je veux dire s'il vous
plaît à
voila voila boukella voilà après tout ce
qui s'est fait taper dessus benjamin par
toute la presse parce qu'elle a eu le
courage de dire certaines choses et
maintenant il essaye un peu de se
rattraper tout mais la vérité est ce
qu'elle est la vérité moi j'ai rien
contre lui je vais j'aime bien ça se
voit
mais
vous vous étiez parler avant que le
livre sorte on s'est parlé et quand j'ai
découvert qu'il voulait faire en fait un
livre à charge et d'ailleurs non non pas
du tout qui est qui écrit achats
d'ailleurs une minime une citation au
début oui mais où mais qui dit ça il est
pas un biographe qui trempe sa plume
dans la guimauve oui mais voilà ces
votes c'est que vous avez trompés dans
la merde
exercée si c'est si facile écrit ça donc
c'est super mais je vous le dis les
grandes passions et puis la mère a pas
suffisants aient pu la merde il pue la
merde et
puis la merde
[Musique]
à ses qualités c'est un homme à rouyn et
allemandes écrit des choses sur moi je
n'ai rien moi même ma mère et je reviens
vers a écrit un livre et comprenait la
part de ma mère est générée
laissez le parler et carole amiel tu
sais moi c'est mon passe temps mais ça
swingue oui mon bâtiment mais moi je moi
je voulais une chose montant il est mort
il ya trente ans aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
voilà je trouve ça inutile c'était
certainement comme beaucoup de joueurs
connus avec des avec des zones dont moi
je trouve que trente ans et ça n'a pas
grand intérêt ça n'a pas grand intérêt
moi j'essaie depuis quelques années de
réhabiliter et à la fois ma grand-mère
et la fois mon temps et vous dit des
horreurs sur ma grand mère je veux même
pas dessus parce que ça ça va débarquer
ce qui ne remet pas moi non géré mais ça
me donne envie de gerber de gerbe et dit
que sa grand mère c'est même pas la
peine de répéter les quatre
mois
j'ai interrogé des gens qui ont connu
des gens jettent affirmé non c'est un
livre d'histoire jeu c'est une histoire
rien et du montant c'est un personnage
public les gens ont ils bien sûr les
gens l'aiment après avoir lu sur wii
abonnés super oui bonjour je fais une
biographie sur vous avancez devant vous
moi j'allais vous allez voir le verre à
istres est que ça passe aussi alors
j'aimerais qu'on vienne chez moi se
récrie souffler simple à vivre moi
j'écris mais s'il vous plaît et manu
alemagna j'ai pas de [ __ ] j'ai fait
moi-même mais moi mais moi pauvre nage
je les dédie j'aime écrire et ouvrez là
d'un bateau tu me commence à me faire
chier je te le dis théo 10 h et des
gaves et nordine khabzaoui la lettre
c'était une horreur réservoir c'est pas
une longueur heurter une horreur contre
qu'un bouffon tu as tu as entre tu as
moi j'ai débuté chez chez bernard pivot
pour mon premier vous bat les grands
cépages à tapas y chez lui chez michel
drucker pour edith piaf michel drucker
connais mes qualités j'ai eu un prix au
téléphone il m'a fait des confidences
que je répèterai pas ici si tu paies
emmanuel emmanuel vous parler de la
question de l'héritage derrière celle
des enfants cachés celle de l'héritage
qui montant si un enfant caché avait été
reconnu il aurait fallu partager un peu
plus eric récemment ordre sarr a été
reconnue de la corse est une enfant que
il monte en a une relation avec un en
dhr sarr qui était une jeune actrice
voilà la voilà ça c'est sa fille anne
resort à une relation qu'il était niée
par mon temps quand il a été interrogé
par la police mais en retard ne cherchez
pas l'argent pendant 14 ans il a vu la
fille la petite île essayer de créer un
lien filial et quand elle a vu que
valentin arrivait et que montante je
suis content d'être père pour la
première fois là c'était trop pour elle
donc elle a attaqué il ya deux ans dans
get des attestations de claude sautet
qui a été qui a subi d pression et qu'il
aura été reconnu comme la fille de mon
temps non pas sur une simple
ressemblance c'est vrai qu'avant jamin
il ya eu alors je vais lui il fait le 7
500 personnes et procèdent donc à 100
avec son histoire il ya eu effectivement
une demande pas tannés de la part de
madame brossard il se trouve qu'il ya eu
un test un peu tests génétiques et était
sur la soeur de mon temps et sur
valentin c'est de laisser mon fils
allait arrêter dire des conneries c'est
très bien c'est le fils et ma fille a eu
à diriger du délit
si tu m'écoutes nom s'est vendu à 6 mois
je sais c'est le petit fils d'immigré
peut nous dire donc l'ère du soliste et
c'est la folie des masses voilà dont il
le promettait ce qui a été fait en plus
cette histoire allait juger entériné ça
n'est pas la fille d'yves montand vous
pouvez monter descendre décrire votre
bouquin dire ce que vous voulez allez
voir il a frère ma mère ma mère lui qui
vous voulez mais non mais je lui disais
cela va le buzz le plus grand animateur
de france l'autre soir et qui savent
très ami avec vous vous ai pas eus au
téléphone
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cédric et je vous parlais de bruyckere
vous voulez que je l'appelle en direct
non mais michel chassang de 0,6 bien sûr
on va laisser tranquille
alors moi je c'est une affaire mais
christophe
matata et on va revenir alors on vient
j'ai fait une enquête de quatre ya
quatre chapitres comme ça tout le monde
il ya déjà des énormes des anomalies
terrible le la dernière personne qui
part dans ce livre c'est l'avocat
maurice olivier il dit au vu de ce
dossier je considère que la fille et on
rentre ça de mon point de vue est bien
la physique après je vais revenir et
qu'il souffre depuis 30 ans emmanuel je
veux revenir sur un autre dossier que
vous révéler dans le livre un autre des
grands secrets autour du montant que
vous réveillez dans le livre sont les
rumeurs au sujet de ses aventures
homosexuelles dans votre livre vous
dites qu'il a une relation avec
l'artiste reda caire qui était à
l'époque une énorme star mais ça me
faisait marrer sa carrière c'est bien
moi qui l'ait sans relancer ça car il a
dit qu'il a sorti voilà kore eda caire
oui ben c'est un métier on n'arrive pas
comme ça vous savez comment ça se passe
et n'a alors pas tout
non mais du niveau de mon temps là merci
voilà il est pas loin
ça veut dire que vous êtes inquiet il a
fait sa part en opportunisme bien sûr
pourquoi vous étiez avec lui vous savez
ça brille il faut lire le livre mais c
'est j'ai regardé jean claude brialy la
sortie sans skis à ce qu'il est triste
qu'il a rogné ils vont m'entendre et cet
homme c'est de l'art revenir et
d'acteurs et sous celle de la galerie
des halles un rédacteur du a écrit un
jour il lui a dit si tu dis est ce que
c'est moi j'habite juste à ce geste en
moto si tu es je viens alors faites
gaffe c'est mon dos des montagnes
merci alors et non mais il paraît qu'ils
ont même vécu ensemble ces histoires oui
son vécu à la farouk est et saint macary
c'est non mais mon temps en public et il
avait renié mais en privé ils copient
coïc il lui a conservé des relations
avec lui ça prouve qu'il avait gardé son
estime pour lui mais il faut se remettre
dans le contexte de l'époque
l'homosexualité était un des listes est
un crime un machin voilà c'est tout
petit puis ça regarde passer regarder
personne
benjamin so what si vous le saviez pas
donc moi non mais bon jean claude brialy
la cia lombez japonais très bien briller
lille c'est vous et j'avais beaucoup de
réponses pour briller elle est
effectivement ils ont libéré des mobiles
mais écoutez quand bien même c'est vrai
franchement excusez moi il était en
avance sur son temps voilà alors je lui
mets tout je ne critique pas se dit m on
dit même que pour éviter c'est choquant
qu'en soient choqués de salins parce que
vous raconter des trucs qu'ils font avec
eux pourrait vite pour éviter de partir
en allemagne pendant la guerre et
montant aurait même participé à des
parties fines avec son amant et le chef
de la kommandantur sas au conditionnel
on raconte que ce métier au congo
conditionnelle vous écris menons avec
comme autre témoignage tout leur monnaie
franchement
ça va être pas d'arrêter montré il ya le
témoignage d'un père noël a très bien
connu simone signoret pendant la guerre
effet votre
bouquet droit de faire ça simone
signoret
je vais passer en mer si je devais
adopter tous les enfants de mon temps
j'aurai une famille nombreuse voilà
c'est tout il ya des gens qui souffrent
qu'ils sont vivants aujourd'hui c'est
tout moi je j'ai fait un travail on m'a
demandé d'écrire ce livre je voulais
paix car son cas je voulais si parce que
c'est un personnage génial et voilà
c'est tout je savais par p il y avait
d'autres facettes de l huile non moi je
vais j'en ai parlé très bien où il est
benjamin il faut lire tout le rsa j'ai
passé au milan mais ce n'est pas tant
les révéler des choses extraordinaires
non se ressemblent will soon aline sur
son courage civique et ses volets tout
la part des choses et les personnages
publics la personnage historique et
c'est tout le tournage quand on a fait
rien on a la prétention de s'inscrire
dans l'île où
je regarde à dire que là s'il vous plaît
on est à côté
alors c'est bon ça vous rappelez de deux
tu sais voilà on sait que toi les livres
la culture c'est pas ton tout
cultiver sans compter l'image de sa de
sa mentalité c'est toi tu me tape dessus
je te réponds je te ménager des
arguments débat tv dessus c'est tout ce
que j'ai fait ça te plait pas tu
attaques judiciairement c'est tout tu
dis pas on va venir au match
de jeudi à l'ats sur téléphone moi je
dis j'y suis moi même et grands parents
et oui mais moi tu l'as salit la mémoire
de ce n'est pas ça nous redonne des
sarments rude et moi je vous jure que ça
fait
là même qu'il arrête de dire ça à mes
bouquins et à des conneries je les lui
ton bouquin je les luttes en bout cage
les amas attention je les benjamins
attention attention attention c'est non
encore sur attention attention
tu t'es fait taper par dessus par toute
la presse benjamin
j'ai vu que les cellules parlé un petit
peu de soupe et le petit manuel emmanuel
encore plus cette manière dans une foule
immense et il est libre il s'est agi dit
ce qu'il dit est faux encore 50 rebonds
cyril d'amélie les bains comme au bout
il ya une phrase mon bouquin sera sur un
fait voilà c'est ça quand j'avais besoin
de parler ouais il a été
arrêté comme il était interprété il y
avait gagné avant leurs proches changer
dix à vingt ans aujourd'hui ont leur
rôle à remonter on a fait deux mois et
roger bien de le faire je les fais je ne
riais vous de juger je viens 20 jeunes g
je vous le demande je
la laisse à ne pas mais tu as bien fait
de le faire céder c'est le mari laissé
la prière emmanuel j'ai bon c'est bon ça
c'est fait bailly filet pour faire son
show pour faire ça non je suis pas là où
souffle le vent
qui est malade et je suis venu tard je
sois arrivé vous avez la logorrhée ted
achève de sont en situation de serrer la
beagle et déjoue toutes les deux minutes
je pars à la non vous parlez pas elles
sont aux manuels donc je vous souhaite
de vendre plein de bouquins je suis
d'accord l'argent à banamba oui bien
vous on est en plein délire largeur et
en mai écoutez moi je voulais l'argent
sera un autre métier il fait que parler
ce possible alors emmanuel juste
dernière histoire que vous voulez
aborder c'est le sujet de cette famille
l'histoire d'amour entre les deux
montants il marilyn monroe qui était une
immense actrice un scoop en a pas
beaucoup et bonne nuit pour le savoir
marie je n'ai pas cette prétention à
valeur non mesdames si vous êtes
d'autres prétentions pour certains
maritime sûre est même tombée enceinte
du montant oui ça c'est une révélation
d'une amie de marilyn monroe qui avait
qu'à voir île secrète très longtemps
elle avait aucun intérêt à mentir mais
c'est pas la première avant n'y avait
pas de télé pas de préservatif faut se
remettre tout ça dans le contexte d'un
choc aujourd'hui leur ennemi tout à ses
trousses mais mais voilà ces mêmes et
mais bon je vais pas juger de ça moi je
quittais lui livre autour de la table
gibert d un livre très dérangeant pour
moi le problème c'est que c'est un livre
à charge et vous appuyez partout ça fait
mal et vous qui le sont et htc joris
élus d'autres noms comme jean des
spécialistes du spectacle et c'est moi
c'est parce que c'est un livre hyper à
charge et vous tirez chaque fait dans le
sens qui vous arrange par exemple sur la
sphère drossart il a été exhumé va pas
on va pas entrer dans les détails que je
voulais dire c'est que chaque affaire
c'est bon il va pour taper sur yves
montand moi ça m'a dérangé je lui ai dit
je suis
je rapporte des faits non non non moi
j'ai lu aussi le libre il rejoint le
documentaire qui a eu hier sur france 3
il ya pas longtemps et notamment sur la
bisexualité c'est exactement
effectivement qu'on m'avait raconté
brialy exactement comme un tabou s'est
passé c'est pas ça qui me dérange c'est
pas le fait qu'il a il dit y ait des
choses vraies ils ont marine c'est vrai
c'est pas lui qui l'a révélé c'est là
que les choses qui sont vraies ils y ont
fêté aucun scoop dont ce livre c'est pas
ça que je reproche c'est ce besoin
effectivement de faire un témoignage à
charge qui est délibérément fait avec un
ton petit petit petit qui est pas
agréable n'est pas sympathique dès le
début vous traitez de cabo vous parler
de son livre se soigner dans le gris les
morts et les vivants si vous laissez pas
finir ça va mal se finir à chaque passe
je vais quitter le plateau ça suffit
maintenant dont vous parlez et vous vous
parlez de choses mais voilà il est
membre dans un lit trop petit pour lui
vous le tourner en ridicule vous ne
respectez pas été grand c'est tout
pourquoi en ridicule aussi de parler
c'est lui qui faisait le cargo dans la
tente de la merde quoi simone signoret
ta maman elle raconte que quand simone
est mort il faisait le cabba tempête sur
la plaque tomba la bomba c'est tout
c'est le spectacle à cabo c'est un hymne
à la loi ni nos véritables content merci
manuel
mel bonis véritable vocation
[Applaudissements]
merci en tout cas la vanille la bomba
jamais imposé vous serrez vous vous
parlé tous les deux je pars pas lui mais
il m'a raccroché au nez leur demande
intérieure convient
pas bien vue dans
ce match ils sont mes grands parents je
raccroche au nez
[Rires]
allez merci merci
merci madame à aller